Now that you have practiced using so
many new tools and
concepts, it's time to embark
on your final project.
You will create a menu app with Flask
that lists out all the restaurants in
your database and allows you to view
the menu for each of those restaurants.
Users should also be able to create,
read, update and
delete restaurants and their menu items.
You will be the technical
lead on this project and
I will not be telling you line
by line how to write your code.
Note that the code presented in these
next challenges will help you make
a basic final project.
But I strongly encourage you to
go above and beyond by making
a unique creation that you can call
your own and share with others.